OK, let's get started.
So now, let's talk a bit
about a recap of the online RL
methods that we've
talked about, so far.
So we started with talking
about policy gradients, where
our goal was to collect
data from our policy,
then increase the
likelihood on actions that
led to above average outcomes.
So encouraging the
policy to do more
of the stuff that
led to good outcomes,
less of the stuff that
led to bad outcomes.
And then we started introducing
this notion of a value function,
which can then estimate.
We can use a value function to
estimate how good an action is,
and then when we fit
a value function,
we can use that to then
encourage the policy
to do more of what you estimated
to be good and less of what you
estimated to be bad.
And we saw a couple
algorithms, like PPO and SAC,
that use this actor
critic approach.
We also talked about a few
different ways for fitting value
functions, and I want to quickly
go through these different ways,
again, because
it's actually going
to play a pretty important
role in today's lecture.
So the first thing
we talked about
is, if you have some
state in your data,
and you want to estimate
the value of that state,
one way to do that is to
take the sum of the rewards
over the trajectory
in the future
and estimate the value that way.
So the target would be you'd be
trying to fit some V pi of S,
and your target would be the
sum of rewards from that state
onward.
So you'd be trying
to contrast this
with the sum of rewards
at future time steps--
from future time
steps, from t to t.
And then your objective
for your value function
would look something like
this, where you're then
trying to minimize this over the
states and actions in your data
set.
So that was the
first simplest way
that we saw to estimate
a value function.
And then we saw a way
to potentially get
a better estimate.
Because instead of just
summing all the rewards,
you could actually look at
your estimate of the value
at an intermediate state.
So say that this is S prime
is your next state right here.
Instead of looking at the
sum of rewards from there,
instead you could look at what
is the reward at the next time
step plus the value--
my estimate for the value
at the next time step.
And use that as
your target, where
instead of being
the sum of rewards,
the target would be the reward
at the current time step
plus the estimated value
at the next time step.
And this is alternative target
for fitting a value function.
And so the full
objective would be--
whoops.
The full objective would
be something like this.
And we're trying to minimize
this over our data set.
We could say our value
function has parameters, phi.
We called this bootstrapping or
TD updates, temporal difference
updates.
So that was the second way that
we saw for estimating a value
function.
And then we also
saw a third way.
So in these two
scenarios, the data set
is sampled from your policy.
These were on policy
methods for estimating
the value of a policy.
So these were scenarios,
where your data
set was sampled from the policy
that you're trying to evaluate.
And we then started to look
at a scenario, where what
if your data set is sampled from
some mixture of old policies?
Could we use that data in
order to fit a value function?
And to do that, we started
looking at Q-functions.
And with Q-functions, we
can again use something
like bootstrapping,
where in principle, we
could use something like Q
hat pi of phi of s t, a t,
we're trying to estimate this.
And then we could also
use this as our target,
with the caveat that
this value function is
going to be for the
policy and the data
and not for the policy
that we're trying to learn
and the policy that we're trying
to learn a value function for.
And so what we did instead
is we changed our target
to use the Q-function.
So we had the target as
s t plus 1 a t plus 1.
And the key difference
here and s and a,
and s t plus 1 are
sampled fro the data
Set.
But a t plus 1 is going to
be sampled from the policy
that we're trying to learn
a value function for.
Cool.
So that's a quick recap
of some of the things
that we talked about.
And these are the different
ways of estimating
value functions, with the key
difference of this last one,
being something that we can
use data from old policies for.
Now, one really important
aspect of this last one
is that because we're
bootstrapping and using
our own estimate of
the value function
at a given state
as the label, we
need this Q-function to be
trained on actions that actually
would resemble the
actions that we're
going to be evaluating it on.
And so if our policy is
very different from our set
of old policies, this
label will not be accurate.
And then we won't be able to
learn an accurate Q-function.
So it needs good
coverage over action.
Cool.
And then those are
the different ways
of learning value functions.
The full off-policy
actor-critic method
looks something like this, where
we took data from our policy,
stored that in the buffer
that had a number of data
from a number of past policies.
Sampled some data
from that buffer,
updated our Q-function
with these targets,
and then updated our
policy to encourage
it to increase the likelihood on
actions that had a high Q-value.
And then we can
repeat that process.
So for today, we're going to be
building on some of those ideas.
And specifically,
we're going to be
talking about offline
reinforcement learning.
And in offline
reinforcement learning,
we're trying to learn from a
data set that was given to us,
not collected by our own policy.
And we'll then talk about
two different methods
or two different
classes of methods
for doing offline
reinforcement learning.
And the key things that
we'll try to see is--
I talked about is, first,
the key challenge that
arises in offline RL.
Second, two different
approaches for offline
RL and why they work.
And lastly, how offline
reinforcement learning
can improve over just
imitation learning, which
is another way to learn
from offline data sets.
The question is,
is this Q-learning?
This is actually
two lectures ago.
This is soft actor-critic.
In Q-learning. , there is
one last change to this.
So in this case, we're trying to
learn Q-function for the policy
that we're learning.
The difference that
we saw in Q-learning
was we were actually trying
to learn the Q-function
for the optimal policy.
And in Q-learning-- this
red marker is not great--
our target was instead--
instead of sampling
from the policy
that we're trying to learn
a value function for,
we tried to pick an action that
was the best action according
to that Q-function.
And so our target was
of s t, a t, plus gamma.
And then we were taking a
max over the next action
so that we were
actually trying to--
and our goal here was to
try to learn the Q-function
for the optimal policy.
And this was also
something that can
be done off policy, without
data from the optimal policy,
as long as your estimates
have good coverage.
So in offline
reinforcement learning--
first, why offline
reinforcement learning?
So the process for offline for
online reinforcement learning
is, you collect data.
Then, you update
the policy, either
using the latest data
or the data, so far.
And then you repeat
that process.
With offline RL, you're
actually just given the data
set in advance.
And then you want
to train a policy
on that provided data set.
So you're not actually
iteratively collecting data.
And there's a number
of circumstances
where offline reinforcement
learning might
be more useful than online
reinforcement learning.
The first is that when you're
trying to approach a problem,
you might already
have a data set that
was collected by an existing
system or by people,
and collecting data from your
current policy might be risky
or might be unsafe.
So, for example,
if you're trying
to learn a policy
for controlling a car
to drive on roads,
you might have
a lot of data of
people driving, that
could be very
useful for learning
a good policy for driving.
And it might be
unsafe to actually try
to deploy your policy,
especially a policy that
is not very good at driving.
In other circumstances,
people have
looked at using
reinforcement learning
for figuring out good
ways to treat people
in medical scenarios.
So, for example, there
was a really cool project
on a seizure
prevention use case,
where you're trying to learn
a policy for figuring out
how to prevent seizures.
This is a scenario
where if you have
an offline method of some
existing system, then
you could use that to learn
a policy, without having
to collect data
from a policy that
is not good in the first place.
And then the last
point, which is actually
a little bit more nuanced,
is that if you actually
run online or all
multiple times,
you might actually already have
a data set from your policies.
And it would be
really nice to reuse
that data set rather than
trying to recollect data
every single time you
try to run an experiment.
If, for example, you're training
a robot to do something,
and you want it to learn
how to grasp something,
then if you have a
pure online RL method,
it means that every single time
you need to run your algorithm,
you need to recollect
data from your policy.
And that can be pretty
inefficient, because probably,
the first time you run
the algorithm isn't--
you still room for iteration
on the algorithm itself.
And generally, online data is
more expensive than offline data
for that reason, because offline
data, you can reuse many times.
Also worth noting that
you can blend offline
RL and online RL, where you
have some existing data set.
Like in autonomous driving,
you have a data set
of people driving, and then you
want to train a policy on that.
And then you try to improve
it with some online data
collection, perhaps
with a safety driver
after you have a policy
that's pretty good.
And there's a number of
real-world use cases, where
you will want to blend it.
Because if you actually
are deploying your policy,
then it's great to
be able to improve it
after you deploy your policy.
Yeah.
So the question is, can you view
offline RL as a special case
of online, but
off-policy RL, but where
you don't know the data.
And that's definitely
one that's very--
that's a correct way to view it.
One thing that is a very strict
requirement in offline RL,
in pure offline RL, is
that you have no ability
to collect more data.
And in that sense,
it's not really
a special case of online RL.
Because in online off-policy
RL, you can collect more data.
That said, we'll see that
some of the techniques
will draw upon some of
these off policy techniques
from an algorithm standpoint.
Because in these
scenarios, you're
able to use data
from old policies,
and that's very
useful when you have
an offline data set from some
policy that you don't know.
So now let's talk about this
a little bit more formally.
So say that you're
given some data set,
and the data set, maybe,
has some trajectories in it.
Maybe if it's a
driving scenario,
then you have some car, and you
have data sets of people driving
in a number of different ways,
in a number of different places,
with a number of different cars.
And we're going to say
that this constitutes
some data set that we're given.
And it's helpful to formally
think about the policy that
collected this data.
Now, we don't know
the underlying policy.
So for example, if this
was collected by people,
we don't know what--
well, first, it was
collected by multiple people,
then it's multiple policies.
And we also just don't
directly have access to that.
But it's useful to
think about that policy,
just from a
mathematical standpoint.
And so we'll say that this
data set was collected
by running some policy that will
refer to as the behavior policy
or pi beta.
And if it's collected
by multiple policies,
then you can think of pi beta
as a mixture of policies.
And you can define that mixture
as some average or weighted sum
over some constituent policies.
So we don't lose any
generality by saying that it's
collected by a single policy.
Cool.
So that's the data set sample
from some unknown policy.
Maybe a mixture of policies.
If we were to think about the
distribution over this data,
we could think of it,
having some underlying state
distribution, corresponding
to this policy, an action
distribution dynamics,
a reward function.
And then our goal is to
learn a good policy that
maximizes reward.
And so ideally, we would be
able to take this data set
and be able to learn some
policy that can control the car.
And ideally, it's maybe
a pretty good policy.
Maybe some of the times, it
does merge into another lane.
But generally, we want a policy
that will refer to as pi theta.
And we want to be able
to ultimately maximize
an objective, corresponding to
the sum of rewards for how good
this policy is.
And so you can think
about that as maximizing
the parameters of
this policy and trying
to maximize for trajectories
sampled from this policy,
maximizing the sum of rewards.
Or, well, either--
I guess I'll write it
as r of r of trajectory,
where this is the sum of
rewards for individual states
in that trajectory.
Now, one thing to note
here is that this objective
is an expectation
over this policy.
Whereas, our data was collected
by a different policy.
And so we can think about this
as there being some distribution
shift between the
policy that collected
the data and the policy
that we're deploying.
And we don't actually get
to sample from that policy.
And so that's one of
the big challenges
in offline
reinforcement learning.
So there's this
distribution shift
because this expectation
is under the learned policy
rather than under the policy
that collected the data.
And then it's worth
mentioning that the dynamics
of the environment
are going to be
constant between the data
and the learned policy.
So the distribution shift is
only for these trajectories.
It's only caused by the
shift in the policy.
The question is, if the data
set is comprehensive enough,
can it turn out that
the learned learn
policy and the behavior policy
distribution are identical?
Generally, that's
extremely rare.
Generally, that doesn't happen.
And the reason is that,
usually-- well, first, you
often want to improve
over your data set
and learn something that's
better than the average driver.
And so in that case,
you might actually
end up with a
narrower distribution
here than your original policy.
In the case where your
original policy is very good,
then you're somewhat more in an
imitation learning like setting,
and you might still
diverge and drift away
from the distribution
in the data set.
Where does the data come from?
It can be human collected
from some hand-designed system
or controller.
It could also be from previous
reinforcement learning runs,
that you want to reuse.
It could be a mixture
of these sources.
Lots of different places
the data could come from.
Now, there were some
comments about how
this offline reinforcement
learning relates to off policy
reinforcement learning.
And one natural
question is maybe
we could just reuse an
off-policy algorithm.
And just run that
off-policy algorithm,
but using the offline data set
rather than recollecting data
with our new policy.
Does anyone have
thoughts on what
will happen if you use
an off policy algorithm,
like soft actor critic
on an offline data set?
Yeah, so the thought there
was that we have this--
we're evaluating our
Q-estimate on actions sampled
from our policy, and
our policy is also
trying to increase likelihood on
Q-values on states that have--
or on actions that
have high Q-values.
And if we have an
offline data set,
and we're learning
a policy that's
different from the policy
that collected the data, then
this Q-estimate that
we're supervising,
we're using to supervise our
Q-function may not be accurate.
Because it didn't
actually necessarily see
actions in the data that come
from the policy we're learning.
And so we might actually end up
learning an accurate Q-function.
And if we don't learn
an accurate Q-function,
then we might get a
bad policy as a result.
And so to walk through
that a little bit more,
let's say that
we, maybe, again--
you can have a little
bit of space here.
So let's say that we have our
data set and some of the data.
Here are a few of the
actions in the data.
Maybe this is a1.
This is a2.
This is a3.
And there's other actions
that the car could take
that's not in the data set.
So for example,
maybe the car could
go on an adventure over here.
Maybe that's a4.
The car could also
make a U-turn.
That's a5.
The car could also go backwards.
Maybe that's a6.
So there's all actions
that the car could do.
And at the beginning
of training,
we're going to be randomly
initializing our Q-function.
And so if you think about some
randomly initialized Q-function
for a given state, maybe
it looks somewhat random.
And this is for
different actions.
Then only some of these actions
are present in the data.
And so maybe a1, a2,
and a3, maybe they're
all within this range.
So this is what's like in
distribution in the data.
And then outside of
that, your Q-function
is somewhat arbitrary.
And you don't actually see
any data for outside that.
And then when you
do a policy update,
your policy is going
to say, oh, maybe
let's try to increase
the likelihood on actions
that have a high Q-value.
This is actions a, Q of s, a.
Then what it will do
is, it'll say, OK,
for this randomly initialized
Q value, maybe something
like this looks good.
And then if that's
outside your data,
then it will still
continue to think
that that's a good action
because it'll never
actually know what the proper
Q-value for that action is.
And so walking through that,
basically, everything--
Maybe another way to think about
this is that here's your data.
Here are some of the actions
that are out of distribution,
including a4, a5.
It never saw a car
that, for example,
makes a U-turn on the highway.
And so the Q-value is
randomly initialized for that.
Some of those actions that
are out of distribution
will arbitrarily have
higher key values.
Some will have lower because
it's randomly initialized,
and then your policy will
exploit those inaccuracies
on the out of
distribution actions.
So on the slides, we have
this term right here.
When you evaluate this
Q-function on a prime
that's not in the
data set, if you
have some randomly initialized
Q-function for that state,
and your data support
only covers part of that,
then on the
out-of-distribution actions,
your Q-function
will be unreliable.
And then when you do
your policy update,
that's going to seek out
actions, where the Q-function is
overoptimistic.
And then after
the policy update,
these key values will
be overestimated,
because now you're going
to keep on reinforcing
that was good behavior, even
when it's not in your data.
Another perspective
on this is that this
will happen in scenarios where
your learn policy is deviating
too much from your
behavior policy.
Because these
out-of-distribution actions.
These are things that are very
different from what the behavior
policy did.
And if we stayed closer
to the behavior policy,
then we wouldn't
have this issue.
The question is, what happens
if you have a discrete action
space?
So basically, everything
will be the same.
It's possible that
your data set,
if in all the states
in your data set,
it has full coverage
of the actions,
then you won't have this
problem because everything
will be in distribution.
But in practice,
usually, there will
be states, where you don't have
full coverage of all actions.
And you can still see
overestimation in those states.
Yeah, so the question
is, can you just exclude
out-of-distribution
actions, when you're
updating your Q-function?
Yeah, and there are
approaches for doing that.
Now, the unfortunate
thing is we don't actually
know what's in distribution
and out of distribution.
So we have just samples
of states and actions.
And for a given
state, you might have
one state that then chooses a1.
Then you might
have another state
that's not exactly the
same, but very similar.
And that takes a2.
And so in that case, a2
might technically not
be seen for the first state.
But you don't
necessarily know-- you
don't know for a given
state, what's in distribution
and what's out of distribution.
And yeah, we'll basically see--
basically, a key idea
behind offline RL methods
is trying to avoid--
well, first trying
to think about how
do we deviate not too much
from the behavior policy.
And second, can we avoid
out-of-distribution actions?
OK, so let's talk about
mitigating overestimation.
This is really the core goal
behind offline RL methods.
So the one approach to
offline RL is basically
to do imitation learning.
And the reason why
imitation learning works
is that you're only
supervising with actions
that are seen in the data.
And so any approach that
uses imitation learning
is going to be avoiding
out-of-distribution actions,
somewhat implicitly
because you're only
going to be supervising with
actions that are in the data.
Now, we don't necessarily
want to use vanilla imitation
learning because the offline
data may not be optimal.
There might be human
drivers in your data set,
for example, that
don't drive in the way
that you want your
autonomous vehicle to drive.
And offline RL methods
should provide a way
to be better than the
policy that underlies
the data by leveraging
reward information,
by leveraging the
fact that maybe you
can go through your data
set and say that this
was a behavior that was good.
And maybe this was a behavior
that was not as good.
And that reward
information can allow
you to get a better policy.
And then, yeah, vanilla
imitation learning
can't outperform the expert or
what's provided in the data.
The other thing
that I'll mention
is that I'm not sure if
there's an analogous situation.
Maybe there is actually probably
some analogous situation
in driving, but a good
offline RL method can also
stitch together good behaviors.
So if you have--
where to put this?
Say you have-- maybe
let's put it over here.
So say you have some trajectory
in your offline data set
that looks something like this.
And another trajectory
of your data set
maybe looks something
like this, and say
that this one got a
good reward at the end,
and this one got a
negative reward at the end.
Then a good offline RL
method should realize
that this is a good behavior.
And also, the first
part of this trajectory,
if you continue along the
trajectory at the end also
can be a good behavior
and a good offer.
RL method should realize that
when you're in these states,
you should essentially be
able to stitch together
the first part of
this trajectory
and the second part of
the green trajectory.
And if you use vanilla
imitation learning,
you won't get that behavior.
Instead, what it will
do is, in this state,
it will take the average between
these two action distributions.
So what this could look like
is, if you have a couple
trajectories like this,
then we know that S1 to S3
is good behavior.
We know S7 to S9
And so offline reinforcement
learning methods, in principle,
can actually learn how to get a
policy that goes from S1 to S9,
whereas, imitation
learning methods won't
be able to do that.
So before we get into methods
that can do that stitching,
let's first talk about a
very simple baseline method.
So one idea is if you
have a offline data set,
you could also just
take the trajectories
that have high rewards
and only imitate
the stuff that is good and don't
imitate the stuff that's bad.
And that seems like
a reasonable method.
You have some offline
data set that contains
a variety of trajectories.
Then, what you could
do is, you could
define a new data set that
has only trajectories that
have a high reward.
And so what this new data
set would look like is,
it would be all of
the trajectories
in your original data
set, except conditioned
on the reward of that
trajectory, being greater
than some threshold.
And that threshold could be
some percentile of the rewards
in your data set, like the
70th percentile, for example,
only taking the top
30% of trajectories.
And then from there,
you could learn
a policy that maximizes the
likelihood of the actions
in this modified data set.
So that would look like
taking the states and actions
in this modified data set and
maximizing the log probability
of the actions given the state.
So this is the typical
imitation learning objective.
Cool.
So this is, perhaps, our
first offline RL method,
I guess, very, very basic.
Filter the data set to do
the top k percent of data,
and then imitate the
filtered data set.
This is a very
primitive approach
for using reward information.
And it's worth
noting that it's not
able to do this
stitching behavior.
Because what it will do is,
if this is a bad trajectory,
it might just filter out
that trajectory entirely,
and it won't actually
learn how to take
this good behavior and
this good behavior,
and figure out how to
get from here to here.
That said, it's a good baseline.
So if you're going to be trying
out any offline RL method,
it's good to try this first
and see how well it does,
and use that as a benchmark.
And make sure that--
or ideally, try
to make sure that your offline
RL method is doing better
than this.
OK, now, one of the
reasons why I introduced
this is that, arguably, some
of the best offline RL methods
are actually doing
something that's
not all that different
from this, in that they do
have imitation learning
component to them.
And the idea here is that
instead of just taking
the good trajectories, we
could imitate the data,
but weight our
imitation learning
objective based on how good the
action was in that transition.
Now, if you remember what
we talked about with regard
to value functions and
advantage functions,
where the advantage function is
how much better is a t, compared
to what your policy does,
this advantage function
suggests that if we weighted
our imitation learning objective
by the advantage
function, then we
could get some measure of
how good that action is
and get a policy that is
able to learn effectively.
And this will form the objective
of our first offline RL method.
And in particular,
what we'll do is
we will maximize an
objective for a policy that
will be taking the
standard imitation learning
objective, but just weighting it
by the exponentiated advantages.
And this will be a sum over
states and actions in our data
set.
In terms of the choice
to exponentiate them,
there's actually a way to derive
this particular objective.
And I'll mention
that on the slides.
We won't go through
the derivation.
But if you're interested,
we can see if we
can post it after lecture.
And in terms of this objective,
if we have a good advantage
function, and we go back
to the stitching example,
for this particular
state, right here,
we know that the advantage of
this action is high, right?
Because the value, the
Q-value of this is 1.
The Q-value for going this way,
at least in the data, is 0,
and the value of this state
will be the average of those two
outcomes.
And so the advantage for
this one will be positive.
And the advantage for going
this direction will be negative.
And so when we then take our
imitation learning objective
and weight it by the
advantages, we're
going to be telling our
policy in that state,
it should go to the
good outcome rather than
going to the bad outcome.
And so this objective, if you
have a good advantage estimate,
is capable of stitching
together good behaviors
in an offline data set.
And so in terms
of the derivation,
you can show that this advantage
weighted imitation learning
objective is approximating
a KL constraint objective.
Where you can show that
it's maximizing the future
rewards, as measured by your key
value, subject to the constraint
that you're staying close
to your behavior policy.
And this is a pretty reasonable
objective for offline RL.
Because if you're too far
from your behavior policy,
then you won't be able to--
you won't be able to actually
get good information about how
to improve your policy.
So before we talk about how
we estimate the advantage
and what this advantage
will be, any questions
on what this
objective looks like?
Yeah, so the
question is for this
to improve over
imitation learning,
do we need to assume that
our trajectories have
intersecting states?
And the brief answer is
that, no, we generally
don't have to assume that.
And in this diagram,
I actually tried
to have S7 and S3 not be
exactly the same state.
And the reason why we don't
need them to be exactly the same
is that if we're using a
neural network to represent
the policy and the
advantage function,
then it will naturally--
States and actions that are
very similar to each other,
will naturally have
similar outputs
from that neural network.
And so it will be able to--
it should be able to
generalize, if the states
are similar to each other,
but not exactly intersecting.
Now, the degree to this how
well this works will depend on
how close those states are
and how large the data set
is, such that it can learn
a representation that
is collapsing those
representations to something
that looks similar.
The question is,
in practice, do we
need to worry about the
exponential term exploding?
When we look at a practical
implementation of this,
we will actually add a
hyperparameter that corresponds
to the temperature of this.
And so the practical algorithm
will have 1 over alpha times
the advantage.
And that can help prevent this
from getting extremely large.
Yeah.
And then, I guess
it depends a bit--
maybe we'll talk about
it also a bit more when
we get into fitting advantages.
Yeah, I knew this
question would come up.
So when we talked about
actor critic methods,
the objective looked
similar to this,
except instead of
exponentiating,
we just had the advantage here.
The other key difference
was that here, we're
sampling from our
offline data set.
And in the actor-critic
objectives,
the action, well, there's
different versions,
but we're sampling
from an online data set
data set, typically, and
in soft actor-critic,
this action actually
comes from your policy,
not from the data set.
There isn't a very quick
way to derive where
those differences come from.
One, I don't want
to confuse you,
but the one way of
thinking about this
is, oftentimes, online RL
objectives will be optimizing
a reverse scale objective,
and offline are looking more
at a forward tail objective.
But it's a longer explanation.
Yeah.
OK.
And there's also some
references here as well.
So we've talked
about this advantage.
Now, advantage actually
have some policy
associated with them.
It's the advantage of
taking action a in state S,
and then following some policy.
And so the question is--
the first question is,
which policy are we trying
to estimate the advantage for?
For now, we can try to estimate
the advantage of the behavior
policy.
And then a key
question comes up is,
how do we want to estimate this
advantage function, ideally,
in a way that prevents
the overestimation that we
saw before.
So the first way that we
can estimate the advantage
function--
I mean, generally,
it will look very
similar to what we saw before,
when estimating the advantage
function.
But there's a couple
other considerations.
So let's say version--
maybe I'll do this
in a new color.
So let's say version 1, it's v1.
Version 1, we're going
to use the simplest
thing that we had before, which
is to use Monte Carlo returns.
So we can first fit
a value function.
And because we're fitting the
value function for the behavior
policy, we don't need to--
it is coming--
The data is coming
from the policy
that we're trying to evaluate
a value function for.
So if we want to fit a value
function with Monte Carlo
returns, that our
objective looks--
we're trying to regress to
the sum of future rewards.
So our objective looks
something like this.
So this is something
that basically supervised
learning to the future rewards.
And then, once we do this,
which is fairly straightforward,
then the question is, how do we
get the advantage out of this?
There's a couple ways
you could do this.
In the first time
that we saw this,
the way that we got
the advantage function
for a given state and action was
to use the reward plus the value
function at the next time
step minus the value function
at the current time step.
And these are all the value
function that we just estimated.
So you could use this.
The one alternative--
so you could use this.
This is going to rely on
having a value function that
is fairly accurate, because
you're doing this one step
temporal difference
between the reward
plus the value here, minus the
value at the current state.
And so one alternative
thing that you could do
is, instead of using
this estimated--
this reward plus value, which
is basically the estimated
future rewards, if
you start at state t
and take action a minus
your current value is,
instead, you could simply use
the empirical sum of rewards
into the future.
And so this could
simply be the--
and this is going to
be a little bit simpler
and doesn't rely on having
a good temporal difference
between the two.
And so, specifically,
we can first
estimate the value
function by trying
to minimize the difference
between our value estimate
and the sum of rewards.
And then to estimate
the advantage function,
we can take the sum of
rewards for that trajectory
and subtract the value.
In terms of this
particular advantage
estimate corresponds to a
fairly simple and fairly popular
algorithm called advantage
weighted regression.
And I should emphasize that the
way that we did it, previously,
where you used r plus V of
s t plus 1 is also valid.
This simply
corresponds to a method
that is used pretty
commonly, and seems
to work well in practice, when
you have an offline data set.
The question was we
talked about before,
how this is somewhat high
variance, and GAE is better.
You could also use
GAE here, definitely.
This is going to be
a little bit simpler.
But yeah, you could also use
generalized advantage estimation
here.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So the question is, are we
bringing up this Monte Carlo
because, with
offline data set, we
have enough data that sum
of rewards is more accurate,
and we don't have the variance
issues that we saw before?
That's definitely one reason.
When you have a large
offline data set,
variance is a bit
less of a concern.
And these are more accurate.
That said, a big part of
it is also just simplicity.
And it's nice.
Yeah, it's very nice
to have an algorithm,
where you're doing
supervised learning
to fit the value function.
And then you're doing
weighted supervised learning
to fit the policy.
And it's just a very,
very simple algorithm.
Next, we'll talk about slightly
more complicated algorithms
than this version 1, right here,
that can also do a bit better.
So it's still-- even when
you have an offline data set,
there is variance.
More variance in this
estimate than other estimates
that we'll see in a minute.
Now one question that
just to get your brains
thinking a little bit.
So the question
is, what do if you
did this for a deterministic
data set or a policy
that was deterministic
underlying the data set,
what do you actually learn?
And so, as an example,
let's say that we have--
let's say that we
have the car again.
And maybe the car, if
it's in some lanes,
maybe, you just
always go straight.
And you never actually see it,
like turn left or turn right.
My question for
you is, if you were
to run this algorithm, where
you are fitting your advantages,
in this way, on the data set,
what advantages will you learn?
And I'll let you talk
about this for two minutes,
and then we'll
come back, so talk
about this with your neighbor.
OK, let's come back.
Does anyone want to
share what you discussed?
Yeah, so what was said
is that if you're always
taking the same action,
then the sum of rewards
will be the same as v,
because you don't actually
see any variability
in your actions.
And that means that your
advantage estimates will all
be 0.
And then taking that one step
further, if you then plug this
into this equation, if all
your advantage estimates are 0,
then this exponentiated
term is going to be 1.
And then you actually just get
back vanilla imitation learning.
And that's actually--
it's nice that you
get that back because it
means that for this policy,
you actually can't really
do better than the behavior
policy in that
scenario because you
don't see any variability in
different actions you can take.
And so this algorithm
then falls back
on imitation learning
in that scenario.
Yeah, so the question is when
collecting data from offline RL,
does this mean that
you should, sometimes,
deviate from the
expert policy, just
to see more example actions?
And yeah, generally having
more diverse actions
represented in your offline
data set is good for offline RL,
especially if you think
that your expert is not
the optimal thing to do, then
you definitely want variability.
Because, then,
you could actually
have a potential to outperform
the expert in your data.
Yeah, so the question
is, does this
happen very often
in practice, where
your advantage estimates are 0?
So the true advantage
function for this policy
is not 0 for other actions.
It's just that we don't see
those other actions in the data.
And in practice, if you have
variability in the actions,
then you will get advantages
that are very different from 0.
And so, yeah, you
will actually see
a good amount of variability.
It really depends on how
broad your data set is.
Yeah, so the question is, what
would the advantage function
do on actions that are
not in the data set?
So in this objective, we're
actually only evaluating it
on actions in the data set.
And so you don't have any issues
with going outside the support.
Now, if you did
evaluate it on actions
outside the data set
for a different reason,
then it would be not accurate.
It'll just be whatever was the
result of the neural network
optimization.
If it's close to the data,
it might be reasonable.
If it's far from the data, it
might be arbitrarily incorrect.
OK, so the full algorithm is,
we first fit a value function,
using Monte Carlo regression.
And then we train
a policy, where
we weight the
probability of picking
an action or the
likelihood objective
by the exponentiated advantage
estimate, where the advantage
estimate is given by the sum
of rewards minus the value
function.
And we have this
hyperparameter here
that controls the temperature,
or how spiky this distribution
will be.
One of the upsides of this
algorithm is very, very simple.
It's like, yeah, probably
the simplest thing
that you could
implement that has
the possibility of improving
over filtered imitation
learning.
It also avoids
querying or training
on any auto
distribution actions,
which makes it more stable.
That said, Monte Carlo
estimation can be noisy,
and we're learning
an advantage estimate
for the behavior policy, not for
the policy that we're learning.
And so this is going to be--
we can only improve so much over
the data set as a result. Yeah,
so the question is,
this always close to 0.
And why not?
Because you're trying
to fit your value
function to the sum of
empirical sum of rewards.
And then we're taking
the sum of rewards
and subtracting
the value from it.
Now, the reason why, if
you have a broad data
set, that it won't
always be 0, is
that from an individual state,
you will see diverse actions,
and your value function
is going to be--
maybe say this gets plus 10.
This gets plus 1.
This gets minus 5.
Your value function
for this estimate
is going to be the average of
these numbers so that is 3,
I think.
And the sum of rewards
for taking this action
is going to be 10.
And so then the sum of rewards
minus your value estimate
will be seven.
So for this action,
a is equal to 7.
For this one, a is
equal to negative 2.
And for this one, a is
equal to negative 8.
And so when you have variability
from a state or a state
that's very similar to
states in your data set,
that's where you see
differences in outcomes.
And that's where your advantage
functions will differ.
Cool.
Now, it'd be really nice to be
able to not just use Monte Carlo
and be able to use TD updates
or use bootstrapped updates,
without having to query Q on
out-of-distribution actions.
And the issue that we saw
with our previous objective,
right here, was we were
querying the Q function
out-of-distribution
actions right here.
Now, one very simple
thing that we could do
is instead of querying actions
sampled from the policy
that we're learning, we
could just sample a prime
from our data set.
And this is, yeah, a
very simple modification.
And this will prevent--
this will make sure that the
a prime that we're seeing
is actually always
seen in the data.
And we will actually
have supervision targets
for this s prime, a prime.
So this is a very simple
modification to this objective.
And if you estimate the
advantage function in this way
or estimate the
Q-function, and then
use that to estimate
your advantage,
you get an algorithm called
advantage weighted actor-critic.
Now, note this is
getting rid of one
of the weaknesses of
the original advantage
weighted regression
algorithm, which
is that we're able
to use bootstrapping,
but we're still going to
be estimating the value
function for pi beta,
and not for the policy
that we're learning.
So that's still one
downside with this approach.
So from here, it'd be
good to think about
if we can estimate a Q
for a policy that's better
than the behavior policy.
And one of the ways
to think about this
is that, when we're
trying to minimize
this bootstrapped objective,
this target, right here,
this is a sample
of v of s prime.
So like we saw
here, v of s prime,
we're estimating the
mean, the average
of the outcomes, the average
of the expected future rewards.
But actually, there's a
distribution of outcomes
that's represented in the data.
And so if we think about
that distribution--
so we have our value function.
And if we thought about
the value function
for a given state, when you
are taking different actions,
you see different
sums of rewards.
And so there's actually
some underlying distribution
for that in your data,
for a given state.
So one state-- or
maybe a bunch of states
see a reward that that's
like, at this value,
maybe a smaller number have a
higher sum of rewards in them
and so forth.
And then when we do
Monte Carlo regression,
if this distribution has
a mean, maybe, right here,
then this is what
when we do when
we're trying to fit
like the Monte Carlo
estimate for our
behavior policy,
then we get this
average right here.
We're averaging over the
rewards that we're seeing.
Now, if we wanted to
try to learn a value
function for a policy
that's better than pi beta,
we could then--
we could think
about, maybe, instead
of trying to fit the mean
of the outcomes that we see,
maybe we could try to fit
some other percentile.
So this is the mean,
but maybe, if instead,
we could try to fit the 70th
percentile or something like
that, then maybe we could
actually get a value function
for a policy that is better
than our behavior policy.
So how do we do that?
Maybe let's go through
this on the slide.
So we have-- when we're
trying to estimate
rewards plus future Q-functions,
this is a sample of the values.
If we think about a histogram
of the values for a given
state, when we are
using this target,
we're using an
average of the value.
Also, the l2 loss right here
is giving us that value.
Now, the Vs for the policy--
the best policy in the
support of the data
is going to be right here.
And so maybe, there's
some way to try
to use a different loss
function, other than the l2 loss
to get a better policy.
Now, an idea for how to do this.
So when we use an l2
loss, we have some error.
And so this is the error
plotted on the x-axis.
And then l2 loss, we
have something like this,
where maybe let's call this e.
This is e squared.
And if we instead
wanted to get--
if we instead wanted to try to
get a value estimate for this,
what we could do is,
if we instead of having
this symmetric loss that is--
yeah, symmetric.
If you're less than
0 and greater than 0,
you can instead use a loss
function that looks like this.
And you can actually show
that loss functions like this
will actually instead
try-- basically,
you'll be penalized
less for making errors
in a particular direction.
And this will actually
give you a value function
that looks more like this,
that's actually better
than your behavior policy.
Now, specifically,
what this looks like
is, if you think about--
you have some loss function.
We'll call this--
there'll be some--
maybe this is respect to error.
This loss function is going
to behave differently,
if the error is less than 0,
versus if the error is greater
than 0.
And let me just remember
what the direction is.
So if it's less than 0--
so we will have--
and the base case is just
x squared or e squared.
Then, we'll have some
hyperparameter that
weights our loss by some value.
And if lambda is 0.5, then this
is the typical l2 objective,
because it will be e squared,
both less than 0 and above 0.
And if lambda is less
than 0.5, then it
will be downweighting the
loss, when it's greater than 0
and upweighting it when it is--
sorry.
Downweighting it
with it's above 0,
and upweighting it
when it's less than 0.
And the reverse will be true,
when lambda is greater than 0.5.
So what this looks
like is instead of--
I guess I drew it
slightly wrong there.
Instead of using a loss
function, it looks like this.
You can use an
asymmetric loss function
that is penalizing errors
less in one direction.
This is called
expected regression.
It's a cool trick.
You can think about
it in terms of rather
than just error, some
arbitrary random variable x.
And if you define different
values of this lambda term,
then you get these
asymmetric losses
that look like this,
where, again, if lambda
is greater than
0.5, then you see
it as asymmetric in this
direction versus, if it's less,
you see asymmetric in
the other direction.
And here's another
visualization,
where if you're trying to--
the mean of this random variable
is shown in the red curve,
but then, you can
get different tiles
with different values of lambda.
So then coming back
to our algorithms,
if we want to fit
our value function,
we can use this expected
loss and basically
fit a value function
that is trying
to estimate a value
function that's
better than-- for
a policy, that's
better than a behavior policy.
And this will be penalizing
you for overestimating
and underestimating,
but it won't
be penalizing you as much, if
you overestimate a little bit.
Basically, if you're
off by a little bit.
And this means that when you
have these different outcomes,
and these different outcomes
right here, if you get the mean,
you get 3.
Whereas, if you have--
I haven't written down exactly
what the optimum would be.
But for some value of lambda,
it'll be optimal instead.
Instead of outputting
the mean, it'll
be more optimal to
output something
like 6, for example,
where you're
penalized less for
overestimating this value.
And yeah, the
outcome of the loss
function when you use
some things together
will be something that's
higher than the mean.
So in particular,
for this algorithm,
we'll use the expected loss
to fit the value function.
We'll actually also
fit a Q-function
with the typical mean
squared error loss.
And we'll actually use the
value function as the target.
So we'll be fitting both the
value function and a Q-function.
And we'll just be using
this expected loss
for fitting the value function.
And then once we have our
Q-function and value function,
then we can estimate
the advantages Q minus V
and use the same AWR method
to get a policy, where
we're weighting
on the likelihoods
by the exponentiated Q minus V.
Yeah, so the
question is, will we
be overestimating the
value in this case?
So one thing to note
about this algorithm
is, we're never going to be
passing as input actions that
are not in the data.
And that was one of the major
sources of overestimation
before.
Now depending on
how you set lambda,
if you set lambda to be 0, then
you will overestimate probably.
And typically, you'll
choose some value
that's maybe 0.2
or 0.2, something
like that's more in the middle
that's not so aggressive.
And you will be getting an
overestimate of the pi beta.
And the reason
for that is you're
actually trying to estimate
the value of a policy that's
better than pi beta.
So you're trying to estimate.
V pi for a policy pi
that's better than pi beta.
So you're purposefully
overestimating the pi beta.
The question is, because we're
going to be gradually improving
our policy, would it make sense
to gradually decrease lambda?
So we're not actually
collecting data from our policy.
And so all the data is coming
from our offline data set.
And in that case, it makes
sense to keep it constant
because you always want to
be a fixed amount better
than your behavior policy.
Now, if you did in
principle actually
do start collecting
some online data,
then things will change a
little bit, because then you'll
actually be skewing your
data set to a better policy.
And in that case, it actually
might make sense, potentially,
to bring lambda closer to
0, or sorry, closer to 0.5.
Because you'll then have
data from a better policy--
a policy better than
your behavior policy.
So pros of this
algorithm, we don't
need to query out of
distribution actions.
The policy is still only
trained on actions in the data.
And we're decoupling
actor and critic training.
So we just do these
critic training.
We're fitting a value function
and a Q-function on our data.
And then once we're
done with that,
and that's converged, or
we've done enough training,
then we train our policy.
Cool.
So this is an algorithm
called implicit Q-learning.
Yeah, so the question is
where are we fitting Q?
So we could also use Monte
Carlo returns with this
and use the spectral-like
objective with this term.
It's nice to use Q because Q
is lower variance than this sum
of rewards right here.
And we can fit a Q-function,
using the bootstrapped backups.
So all these ideas are
applicable to Monte Carlo
as well.
But using Q-functions,
like when you
can use this bootstrapped
objective, which you could only
do with Q-functions, then you'll
get a lower variance target.
And then I guess to summarize
the point of offline RL.
So online data is
really expensive,
because we have to recollect it
every time we run our algorithm.
And it's really, really
useful to reuse offline data.
One of the big challenges
with offline RL
is this shift
between your behavior
policy and your learn policy.
And we talked about a
filtered or weighted imitation
learning method as a baseline.
And we talked about how we can
actually explicitly constrain
the policy to the
behavior policy
by only supervising the policy
on actions in your data.
And so that allowed us
to get rid or move away
from this distribution
shift problem.
And then the trajectory
stitching idea
that we talked about before
allows us to improve over
vanilla imitation learning.
This example application is for
the algorithm we didn't cover.
If you want to
train offline filter
behavior cloning and
implicit Q-learning
are both good approaches,
but implicit Q-learning
is going to be probably
work better, if you have,
especially if you have
a broader data set.
And if you want to do
offline pre-training
and online fine-tuning, IQL is
actually a very good algorithm
for doing that.
It can also be used with
online data collection
quite effectively, and it
works quite well there.
There's also a
variant of IQL called
IDQL that uses diffusion
policies for your policy class
right here.
And it also works quite well.
And so if you're
interested in diving more
into IQL-like algorithms,
I would encourage
you to check out IDQL.
It is actually--
beyond using diffusion,
it also is a bit
different in terms
of how this update is done.